- Good afternoon, everyone.
Today, we will be
discussing about AI agents
and AWS analytics.
Let me start with a number.
Data teams spend 60 to 70% of their time
on undifferentiated task.
Data engineers are spending
months doing upgrades.
Data scientists are spending
a bunch of their time
on preparing data or analysis
that they can use for it.
And then, platform teams
are firefighting issues.
Now, today, we do have AI assistance.
We do have AI assistance, which
can take you the first step,
which can give you the code.
But a lot of times, these
AI coding assistants,
they're not aware of your
data, of your resources,
of your things that you have done already
in your environment.
And that's why, a lot of the times,
they will give you the
code that will not work
and then you end up repeating
and changing the code,
trying to customize it for your
environment to make it work.
But today, we are going to change that.
I'm Shubham Mehta, Product
Manager for AWS Analytics
and I have been focused on
bringing AI agents to analytics
directly within your workflows.
Today, we are going to
talk about AI agents
that can actually solve the problem
that you're looking to solve.
They can help you upgrade your Spark code.
They can help you build code faster.
Before we get into details,
let's quickly look at the agenda.
We are going to talk about
overall overarching strategy
of how we are approaching AI
agents in the analytics space.
We are going to look
into one of the agents,
which is SageMaker data agent,
and then we are going to look
into a Spark upgrade agent
for Amazon EMR, which can
help you upgrade Amazon,
which can help you
upgrade your Spark code.
Now, before we get into details,
let me first describe the
problem a little bit further.
When we talk with customers,
we hear problems in three specific areas.
First, we are seeing workflow complexity.
Every task that you want
to do in your organization
requires multiple things,
multiple tools to be used,
which means that if you're
trying to build an ML model,
you will end up having
to use four, five tools
for that simple task.
If you're trying to build in Spark,
write an Spark application
or upgrade an Spark application,
you need to understand your build system,
you need to write the Spark code,
you need to upgrade and change
the Spark code, et cetera.
And then, the knowledge gap.
You don't have a single engineer
who is expert in everything.
You have multiple engineers
who are expert in
different, different aspects
of the entire workflow,
where some of them might be good in Spark,
some of them might be good in SQL.
And lastly, we do see the capacity crunch
where the data is growing
10 times every three years,
but the data teams are not
growing at the same scale.
Now, we think that AI agents
can actually solve this problem
because AI agents, the agents
that we are trying to build,
they can orchestrate workflows end to end.
They can actually embed deep
expertise for Spark, SQL,
and other complex engines within them
and they can scale infinitely.
Now, before we get into the agents,
let's look at what are the
guiding principles that we have
for AI agents and the AWS analytics.
Now, four things guide our approach.
First of them, the domain-specific agents.
We think that over the years,
we have learned a lot
about what are the problems
customer face with Spark,
what are the problems
customer face with SQL?
And that's why we are trying to embed
all that expertise in the domain,
in the domain-specific agents.
Second thing,
we want the agents to be adapted
to your role, to your tool.
If you are a data engineer
or a data scientist,
you get a different experience
than what you get as a software engineer.
Thirdly, the multi-agent ecosystem.
We don't think
that one agent can solve all the problems.
Not one engineer was
enough to solve everything.
So, we are building an ecosystem of agents
that can work with each other
to solve certain aspects of the problem
and then collaborate
to solve the entire end-to-end
analytical workflow.
And lastly, we believe in
MCP-based interoperability
because we know that you
are used to using your IDEs,
you're used to using your tools
and you want to utilize these
agents where you're working
rather than going to AWS console
for each and every thing.
Now, let's look into...
We have covered the high-level principles.
Let's see what are the launches
that we have done around
this so that you...
It's not just principles.
We have actually followed these principles
and we are actually making it reality.
So, the first agent that we
have launched just yesterday,
we are proud to announce
Apache Spark upgrade agent.
This is industry's first
Spark automated upgrade agent
where it can take you
through a complex process
of a Spark upgrades from
planning to code edits
to building your Spark application
and doing the data quality test
across the data, across your application.
And this agent is
available as of yesterday
for Amazon EMR on EC2 and EMR serverless,
and it can take you from
Spark 2.4 to Spark 3.5.
Spark 4.0, support is coming soon.
And this entire agent
is based on MCP tooling
where you can...
We are launching a remote MCP server
where you can configure
this remote MCP server
in IDEs of your choice and
you can use it there directly.
Then, after you have
set up the MCP server,
you just say that I want to
upgrade my Spark application
from this version to that version,
and here is the Spark
application in the project
and it will read the code
and it will go through all the steps.
We'll look at the steps
in detail in a second.
Now, it takes you through four steps.
First of them is planning
and orchestration,
where as you give your project,
we analyze the structure of the project,
we see how you're doing
the Spark submit to EMR,
because based on that, the
approach to the agent differs.
We see what kind of language you're using,
do you have integration
test in your project or not,
and based on that, we define
what are the steps we will do
during the entire upgrade process.
And here, you can actually
give the feedback that,
"No, I don't want to take this step,
I want to ignore the integration test.
Can you actually update the upgrade plan?"
And it will upgrade the upgrade plan.
Then, it will look at your dependencies,
whether you have pom.xml
or requirements.txt,
it will go through them,
it will identify that,
"Okay, these are the dependencies
that need change for Spark 3.5.
Let me make those changes."
And it will then go
through your build process
and actually build your application.
Right now, it's supports Maven-based
and SBT-based build,
but because it is MCP-based,
you can bring in your MCPs
to hook into your own custom build process
and actually ask the agent
to use your build process
to build the application.
And then, once it has gone
through all the dependencies,
it will give you a list
of updated dependencies
that you can then verify
and see that, okay, this makes sense,
let's go to the next step.
In the next step, it
actually looks at your code
and looks at all the breaking changes
that Spark has introduced,
and make sure that your code
is not having any of
those breaking changes.
And this entire process
of code modification
is based on error-driven loop,
where we try to run the code
in the EMR cluster that you have given
for the target version.
And we see, okay,
what is the error your
application is facing?
And then, we have built
a first-of-it's-kind knowledge base
of all the Spark breaking changes
where we make sure
that we make the minimal
changes in your code
in order to make sure your
code runs successfully
in the target platform.
And then, the last step
is we make sure that the data
that the application is
producing after the upgrade
actually is exactly same as
the data that you started with
in your prior Spark version.
Because it's not just about
running the application successfully,
it's also about making sure
that the data that it is producing
actually is same as what
it was producing before.
The next release that we
have done in this segment
is data agent.
Now, the previous one was
a domain-specific agent.
In this case,
we have built an agent that is
specific to data engineering
and data scientists and
data analyst persona.
What makes this agent different
is that it is aware of your
business data and catalog.
It uses MCP-based tooling
to get all the information
from your catalog,
what tables you have, what's
the schema of your tables.
And then when you ask
it to write the query,
it actually writes a query
that can run without
you modifying anything.
Now, this agent can also
do multi-step planning.
This can take you from...
This divides the complex task of,
let's say, building a
machine learning pipeline.
It will divide it into five, six steps.
It will take you with each of those steps
and we'll see those in action in a second.
It will take you through
each of those steps
and it will help you
actually write the code
for each of those steps separately,
giving you verification that
things are working fine or not.
And if you run into an issue,
you can actually troubleshoot
using a Spark troubleshooting agent
that is running behind it.
So, let's say you're writing a Spark code
and you ran into an issue.
In this case,
we actually rely on a Spark
troubleshooting agent,
which is the third agent that we have
to fix the Spark-specific issue.
And if it's not a Spark-specific issue,
we resolve it without relying
on the troubleshooting agent.
And it also has security
guardrails built in
where it prevents any destructive
action in your account
where if you ask it to write a code
that deletes your table and all,
it will give you appropriate warnings
and make sure that you're aware
of the actions that you're taking.
Now, I'll go over the demo.
In this demo, we'll take up
a role of a data scientist
who is trying to build
a machine learning model
to predict lifetime value of customers.
And the reason we want to
predict this lifetime value
is because we want to
provide the customers
the right incentive early in their journey
so that we can make sure they are growing
like our business grows with them.
Let's go over the demo quickly.
Now, in this case, we are
in the notebook interface.
On the on the right-hand side,
you have the SageMaker data agent.
We are simply asking,
going through the discovery
phase where we are asking it,
can you list all the tables
that I have in my database?
And it finds out,
"Okay, you have three
tables in your database
that you wanted to look at.
And in this case,
we found out that there's a
digital_wallet_ltv table."
Now, the first thing is I want to see
what is the sample data in that table.
Here, I actually ask it to use Athena SQL
to write a query for this
digital_wallet_ltv table,
and the agent gives me
a very simple query,
we'll SELECT * from sagemaker_sample_db
and this is the new notebook
that we have launched
which actually have interactive,
like, renders the data
frames as interactive tables.
And you can see that what
are the columns I have?
I have this customer_satisfaction_score
and support_ticket and
preferred_payment_method.
Now, I asked the agent,
"I want to explore more.
Can you actually help
me analyze the impact
of customer satisfaction
score on the LTV trends?"
Now, the agent will actually understand
that you are trying to use the data
that you have already
loaded in your notebook
and it will use the data
to actually build further.
Now, if you see, the
agent actually says that,
"Let me create the visualization to show
and I will create the multiple charts."
And in this case, the agent
used the same data frame
that you had loaded using the SQL,
and this data frame is
now used in Python code.
So, these notebooks are
actually polyglot in nature
where you can use the work
that you have done in SQL
and you can use them in Python.
Now, in this case, agent
comes up with graphs, okay?
Like, you can actually see
that with customer satisfaction score,
the LTV is actually increasing.
And the agent has
created this entire code,
I didn't have to edit one single line.
This entire code was written by agent
and running successfully.
And here, the agent also
created this high-level overview
of what is the minimum and max LTV,
median LTV for different
satisfaction score.
Now, we get to the final task.
Okay, I want to build a
linear regression model
to predict LTV and I want
to do a 80 to 20 split,
and I want to use one-hot encoding.
In this case, the agent will
come up with multiple steps
in order to do that task.
So in this case,
the agent comes up with the
code for each of the steps.
The first step is actually...
So in this case,
the agent actually comes
up with multiple steps
and I'll go over the code in a second.
So, you can see,
in the first, code we
are trying to understand,
okay, what are the categorical features
so that I know how to deal
with these categorical features
in my actual run.
So, I identified that there are four
or five categorical features
and I will be using one-hot encoding.
The agent uses one-hot encoding
to actually divide these
categorical features
into multiple steps.
And the agent has produced the
entire code with 23 features
and 18 features were total,
and then the rest of the features
were categorical features
created using one-hot encoding.
And it has created the model
and the model is 81% R2 score,
which means that it is able to
explain the 81% variability.
And finally, it created the
graph for the predicted LTV
where it is able to show
that this was the LTV trend,
and these were the LTV trends.
Like, this were the predicted LTV
So in this case, we created a simple model
but we could have gone
and created a more complex model as well.
And here, we can actually
see the feature importance
where we can see that the low income level
actually decreases the LTV.
But if you have a middle income level,
it also decreases LTV.
But if you have a high
customer satisfaction score,
it increases LTV.
So, you're able to see
that entire code was created
by the agent end to end.
It went through the splitting,
the training and test split.
It went through feature engineering,
it prepared the data for one-hot encoding,
and then it actually did the analysis
and gave you a feature importance.
Now, the same agent,
you can use it for
building data pipelines.
If you're trying to build,
let's say, data pipelines
or you want to run some query on S3 tables
or on Glue catalog,
the same agent can
actually write a Spark code
or DuckDB code or Polaris code
to run those data transformations
using any engine that you prefer.
And in this notebook,
we have actually pre-installed
around 320 packages,
like all the essential
packages that you would need
for your complex analytical
task including SageMaker SDK,
and we allow you, of course,
the freedom of installing more things
in case you would prefer.
Now, if you want to learn
more about these two agents,
I would highly recommend
scanning these QR codes.
These QR codes will lead
you to documentation
and you can see more about,
like, what are the other
capabilities data agent has
and how you can set up
the Spark upgrade agent.
In the Spark upgrade agent documentation,
you can actually see the
remote MCP server configuration
that we have.
So, I would highly recommend you go in,
you use VS code or whatever IDE you have,
you set up the MCP server
and actually use this agent
to do the upgrade for
your sample application
and then use it to upgrade
your production applications.
Now, this is a wrap of
our lightning talk today
on how you accelerate data engineering,
and I really appreciate all of your time
for coming in here and listening to me.